mike snell taking them out here tonight
making his eighth start of deceiving
season 3-0 record era just over three
at 3.14 that's a cut moments and birdie
is out of there on strikes a little
slide ball right there
together now snell to the stretch and
pitches struck him out with a breaking
ball down to retire
the side blake snell strikes out two and
walks one
sandy alcantara will go to work we saw
him last time against these same
raise four plus innings six hits eight
runs five of them were earned
as good as he uh looks early with the
strikeout of wendell is that he never
really lets the game get out of reach
here's sandy's pitch and a swing and a
miss on a high
fast ball at 98 struck him out two down
hard hit on a hop and birdie makes the
play
lewis brinson strolling to the plate
with that little uh
preview and a swing and a miss blake
snell
takes care of him quickly
on a cutting a miss on the fastball up
at 96.
one two three go the marlins a couple of
strikeouts in the first for sandy
and the strikeout here in the second
that was 99.
here comes the next one and that swung
on and missed it 99 miles an hour
he pumped it by tsutsugo scoreless game
top half of
ending three and away from his
that takes care of birdie for the second
time
and that will take care
of and a 2-2 coming to kiermeier
and another strikeout for sandy one away
third baseman anderson on the right side
of the infield against the lefty wendell
the ball in two strikes
and he gets him to chase that one so six
strikeouts for sandy alcantara
two minutes scoring possession no outs
in the fourth looking to battle against
snell
and that will allow a run to score i
thought he fouled that one off i guess
not brinson strikes out aguilar comes in
my goodness on the seventh strikeout for
snell
we'll take it because it's chaos uh
right we got a little cross-up between
snell and perez i think harold's gonna
do something all right right harold in
his first game off the il
up the middle and that's through for a
base hit so harold ramirez does come
through
brings home anderson and the marlins get
at least a pair here in the fort
there's cory dickerson now dickerson
with a fly ball out to deep left center
field way
back and gone a home run for corey
dickerson
a two-run shot and the marlins extend
their lead
this may be corey's best swing of the
year for me anyway
thigh high on the outer third stays on
it and just
unloads i love it
three hits against the rays this year
all home runs sandy back to work
a half swing there from austin meadows
and another strikeout for sandy making
seven
one and one coming from snell to brinson
and this one left side of the infield
backhanded by lao
and that is just air mailed that one
goes
into the raised dugout so aguilar will
come in to score and the marlins have a
five
nothing lead so aguilar scored on a pass
ball
and he has scored on an e4 harold
ramirez has grounded out the shortstop
and singled up the middle and scored a
run
high chopper to third low
and now
harold down in pain still harold ramirez
is down in pain just past the first base
bag he grounded out to third to end the
inning
but his last few steps he came up uh
pretty lame and
in some pain as well one of these steps
was just a little bit of a misstep for
him he knew it immediately went down
in a heap of pain right after he got to
the first base bag jorge alfaro and
jesus aguilar
helping to load harold ramirez on to the
uh cart in still in
obvious pain and that's going to do it
for harold in this one
michael perez single in the third
that's a liner into right field toward
the corner long run for brentson
tsugo digs for third lenara's going to
wave him home
rounding second and stopping there with
the double and a run batted in perez
and the raids are on the board it's 5-1
well did we mention earlier dwayne about
michael perez making his hits count
i mean they're just not meaningless hits
second hit of the night but it drives in
the first run
joy the leadoff double leads from second
and a called strike three doubles up on
the changeup
honestly paul i was about ready to say
don't go back to the change if you just
made a mistake with it he does it anyway
and throws a better one that's what i
love about sandy
alcantara nods yes to the sign
alfaro sets the target here's the pitch
and it's pulled to the left side
picked up there by rojas thrown to first
base for the out and
sandy pitched around a leadoff double
good
work sandy is done after six strong
innings in saint petersburg
as joyce sits for the first time in the
game in the harold ramirez spot
and joyce base hit into left field
that'll score aguilar brinson right
behind him
and matt joyce extends this to a 7-1
marlins lead matt joyce coming through
again against his old team
nice job by joyce just staying inside
the baseball going the other way i love
this this is so deliberate
you got one guy defending you on the
other side you get a base hit you're
driving in two runs
here's michael perez and aligner into
left center field and there for a base
hit
renfro scores satsugo is going to score
the rosarina is going to go to third
perez
drives in two more runs he has
three runs batted in on the night and
that makes it
seven to three with two men on
one to wendell and that to
first and aguilar will take it himself
it's a two pitch save
for kinsler it's a marlins win 7-3 the
score
and the marlins snapped the nine-game
win streak
that the tampa bay rays had over
the miami marlins